the Joe Rogan experience like some
people are in the feet some people are
into getting [ __ ] Oh
segwang and defeat huh yes people are in
defeat have you heard I've heard they're
in defeat I can't believe it well I was
reading up on it that it's the part of
the brain that that handles your
genitals and your feet are right next
they're adjacent so sometimes the white
they think that the wires get crossed
because and the guy that studied it was
a guy who'd studied phantom limb
syndrome and he was so he was following
with these people's brains where they
would feel that they still had a foot or
whatever and some guys would get horny
it would get their brain so it was just
like crossed huh we had a horny thinking
of their own not foot oh
it's hilarious how you pixelate your
feet in all those pictures yeah it's
funny how'd that get started
they just people were they started a
wiki fee account for me I just didn't
know if my feet were thing I just didn't
know I thought I'm just walking around
in you know in slides didn't know I was
walking around he may as well just have
been bottomless I may as well have just
been wearing like pajama bottoms with
the ass flap backwards open just put I
mean my little feet [ __ ] just walking
around so then once people I noticed the
wiki fee thing and then people were
damning me all the time to see my feet
and I just was like you don't get this
whitney shares DMS with us sometimes a
group chat I'm in with Nick Swardson
crystal Ian Whitney and she'll post
pictures of her DMS it's like what in
the [ __ ] yeah they're wild I do with a
thing on my pockets and on my live
stream is sometimes where ice age my
[ __ ] at the end of the night
say Jim I get stage and I just yeah I
just to break the the negative dick
cords that were sent to me the unwanted
dick cords from all these dudes I'm like
yo put your dick cords away but you know
people are pervs what are you gonna do I
just make fun of them but it's more guys
that are pervs than girls that are pervs
with stuff like feet and yeah is there
anything that girls are into that's kind
of gross the money it's so gross but
that makes sense
like money can keep you don't like your
job somebody
like a guy with money fat guys some
people are into I don't know it's people
are not all different things but but not
in the same way it's not the same you're
right it's not the same some guys are
into fat girls too but there's a big
difference between that and feet men are
just very gross you're gross but it's
biologically your dicks are just you're
just ruled by your dicks are just
dragging you through the world right and
it's just got to be acknowledged we
can't pretend this isn't a thing true
just dragging you it's just that's not
we're like breast feeding and [ __ ] we're
thinking about other [ __ ] in archery
there's a term called front of center
meaning how much weight is in the front
of the arrow it different determines
like how much penetration the arrow will
have on an animal I'm getting so horny
this is so weird what are you talking
about it's like the same thing with
dicks
it's like dicks are like your front of
Center it's like yeah no they're just I
I like I feel you guys should be like
holding ourselves back to the doorways
because your dicks are pulling you
through things and it makes life a lot
easier when you just realize that but I
think it's like I just have only grown
up a girl so I just didn't you know I
knew obviously because I've had a lot of
sexual attention even very young but
it's it's just like your dicks our thing
there well there's a reason why there's
seven billion people and it's not
because it's not necessarily because
women are that horny right I think it's
just dude you're trying so hard to [ __ ]
and now hotties compelled I mean this is
a revolutionary thing and it used to be
really hard to stay alive yeah I thought
that long ago yeah now it's really easy
and we're kind of left with the burden
of this shift yeah we haven't our brains
and our biology hasn't really caught up
to the fact that we don't need to have
as many people as we used to we used to
you know used to have a 50% mortality
rate amongst yeah it was very difficult
to survive and I think that's also was
just in China too you're seeing more
shifting with you know like like those
those guys in that video these beta guys
the one guy calling out for people to
stop being distracting and the other one
calling out for people to stop using
gendered language but who are they well
they wouldn't survive if there was
uh you know the the Roman army was
invading but they would have never made
I wonder who's [ __ ] them nobody
nobody maybe they're just men that
aren't driven by that you know no that's
not true that's just as good as they can
get they just beat jeans circle they're
getting attention and stuff yes it's a
mess they're a mess
[Applause]